we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
caller who has an opinion about why
progressives keep losing let's take a
listen hey David I think progressives
I've figured out why they keep losing
it's their arrogance they keep talking
like they think that their policies are
so popular and that is completely
impossible for voters to not like them
and then and also burning but if you
keep going into elections with this I'm
gonna knock down the applecart I'm gonna
fire everybody and you're not willing to
actually work with the existing system
like ALC is starting to realize she has
to do hmm you're never going to win so
in my opinion I don't think progressives
are ever going to win or have any type
of power in this country until they
learn to grow up I for the most part I
mean you guys know my analysis has been
pretty similar to what that caller says
and I believe indeed progressives need
to come to some of these realizations
the entire Democratic electorate is not
as progressive as we would like them to
be and every time I say that people say
no but David everybody loves Medicare
for all you've got to look you have to
look more deeply at those Medicare for
all polls and when you actually provide
more information about Medicare for all
support for it does go down I'm not
saying it is net unpopular but support
is lower than many progressives want to
believe Bernie is not as likable as some
progressives believe him to be and again
you can get mad at me and say I'm just
wrong but you know the two and a half
million vote deficit that Bernie is now
suffering at the hands of Joe Biden it
is not a glitch it is not any of the
things that a lot of people are writing
to me about and I want to win okay and
so we need to come to these realizations
if we all want to win we'll keep talking
about this we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today remember
tomorrow April 9 one-day membership bomb
you will be notified if you are on my
mailing list at 2:00 p.m. eastern of a
massive membership special we are trying
to
recover some of the Lost memberships as
a result of coronavirus sign up for my
newsletter at david pakman.com 2:00 p.m.
Eastern tomorrow you will get a very
special email a very special email and I
look forward to joining you for to you
joining me rather and producer Pat on
today's bonus show in just mere minutes